Pycelle: Without question, Oldtown is the
oldest, wealthiest, and greatest city in Westeros.
Qyburn: Though King's Landing is more populous,
and arguably, more powerful.
Pycelle: The city straddles the mouth of the
Honeywine River, and the bounty of the entire
Reach flows beneath its stone bridges to ports
that are renowned throughout the world.
Qyburn: Thus, we needn't speak more of them.
More interesting is the history of the city,
for none can say when it was founded.
Many centuries ago, a few bold maesters sought
out the Children of the Forest, who claimed
that men have lived at the mouth of the Honeywine
since the Dawn Age.
Pycelle: Nonsense.
Maester Jellicoe proved that the city began
as a trading post where ships from Valyria,
Old Ghis, and the Summer Isles put in to replenish
their provisions and make repairs.
Hence, the most famous feature of the city,
the Hightower, raised even before the city
walls as a beacon through the fog-covered
waters.
Originally built of wood and standing a mere
fifty feet above the ancient fortress of its
foundation, it is now thick stone and rises
even taller than the Wall.
Those born and raised in Oldtown can tell
the time of day by where its shadow falls.
Qyburn: But no maester can tell why.
Even in our oldest records, the island on
which it stands is called Battle Isle.
What battle was fought there?
And when?
As for the ancient fortress that forms the
tower's base, its walls and interiors are
all of solid black stone with no hints of
joints.
Or mortar.
And no chisel marks of any kind.
We know it predates the tower itself by thousands
of years.
But who built it?
How?
And against what?
Pycelle: The maesters who have studied it
declare it to be of Valyrian construction,
akin to Dragonstone and the Black Walls of
Volantis.
As is well-known, the dragonlords of Valyria
could turn stone to liquid with dragonflame
to shape it as they wished.
Qyburn: Didn't one Archmaester link the fortress
to the vanished mazemakers of Lorath?
And another maester to the legendary Deep
Ones who inhabited the Iron Islands before
the Ironborn?
Pycelle: Both marginal opinions without common
support.
But of more importance than the origin of
the tower is the family to which it gave its
name.
House Hightower.The ancient ruling family
of Oldtown.Known for their prudence and love
of peace.
Qyburn: And pieces of gold.
Pycelle: During the Age of Heroes, when Lymond
Hightower saw the Gardener kings conquering
the Reach, he didn't beat them on the battlefield,
but in the godswood.
He bound his house to theirs by marriage.
And transformed House Hightower from wealthy
but relatively minor kings to the greatest
lords of the Reach.
Thanks to Lord Lymond's foresight, Highgarden
has always defended Oldtown, allowing the
Hightowers to focus on higher pursuits such
as learning and trade.
Qyburn: On that, we agree.
When the Andals invaded Westeros, Lord Dorian
Hightower told his wife of twenty years that
wars are bad for trade, and, to make his point,
traded her for a young Andal princess.
When Aegon the Conqueror was earning his name,
House Hightower traded its loyalty to the
Gardeners for his confirmation of their rights,
welcoming him with open arms and open gates.
Pycelle: House Hightower bent the knee to
Aegon to spare the city from his dragons.
I would think such insinuations and insults
beneath even you, Qyburn.
Then again, mockery of one's betters is the
trade of fools.
Qyburn: I wouldn't know.
Perhaps if I'd studied at the Citadel as long
as you, Grand Maester.
Pycelle: The Citadel is the greatest seat
of learning in the known world.
Without it, and the maesters it trains, Westeros
would be a land of superstition and ignorance.
Qyburn: Like the ignorance that shrouds the
Citadel's own birth?
Pycelle: Even without records, we have more
than enough reason to believe that the Citadel
began as a court of scholars and priests assembled
by a second son of House Hightower.
When he died, his elder brother raised the
Citadel so that wise men would always have
a home in Westeros and could continue the
inquiries and debates that had given such
joy to his younger brother.
Qyburn: His little brother's pets, as legend
has it, he called them.
And so the maesters have remained.
Only their masters have changed.
Now they serve every lord with a castle for
a fee, of course, whilst the Citadel serves
its own importance.
Pycelle: Every word you speak merely validates
your own expulsion from our ranks.
Qyburn: Knowledge is validation enough.
I assume the world's greatest minds would
agree.
And perhaps they would if I'd met them.
Oldtown is a city for old men and old beliefs.
Samwell Tarly: The Citadel of Oldtown is the
greatest center of learning in the world,
not that it has much competition, really.
Most lords think of books the way they think
of younger sons, useful to have around as
long as they keep to the corners.
Back when House Hightower still ruled Oldtown
as kings, a crippled younger son sought solace
in books and those who wrote them and became
the greatest patron of learning in his day.
Scholars of all sorts flocked to Oldtown to
debate and write and.
debate.
After this Prince Peremore's death, his brother
granted land to "Peremore's Pets," as the
wise men were called, though now they're known
as maesters.
Viserys Targaryen:The Dance began, as many
dances do, with an old man and a young girl.
The queen had failed to produce a son for
her king, so he anointed his daughter, the
Princess Rhaenyra, as his heir.
But years later, the king remarried, and his
new wife, Queen Alicent of House Hightower,
gave him a son.
Feeble and foolish, the old king refused to
change the succession.
He didn't even see how his court had split
into two rival camps of Blacks and Greens,
after the dresses that the princess and the
queen had worn to some tourney.
One night, a servant found the old king had
died in his sleep and ran to inform Queen
Alicent.
Protocol dictated that the bells would be
rung and a ravensent to Dragonstone to summon
the heir, Princess Rhaenyra, for her coronation.
But Alicent had other plans.
Once she saw her dead husband's body, she
sealed the room and had the servant thrown
into the Black Cells to ensure his silence.
At the hour of the owl, the Lord Commander
of the Kingsguard, Ser Criston Cole, summoned
the small council to inform them of the king's
death.
Ser Otto Hightower, the Hand of the King and
father to Queen Alicent, demanded that the
succession be settled immediately.
The decrepit old men of the small council
were confused; the succession was settled
in their minds.
The old king had forced the lords of Westeros
to swear fealty to Princess Rhaenyra as his
heir.
But Ser Criston Cole rightly pointed out that
a son comes before a daughter.
The council argued until dawn when the Master
of Coin finally stood up and declared he would
have no part of treason.
Ser Criston Cole wisely opened his throat
with a dagger, ending the debate.
None were more surprised to hear of Prince
Aegon's succession than Prince Aegon himself.
At first, the fool rejected the crown, but
his mother pointed out that his sister Rhaenyra
would return such loyalty by taking his head.
As the old king's trueborn son, he'd always
be a threat.
Aegon relented.
He was crowned in the Dragonpit, and his wife
and sister Helaena became queen.
His brother Aemondflew off to win over the
few great lords whose support Aegon didn't
already have.
The banner of the gold dragon flew over King's
Landing and the Red Keep as Aegon, Second
of His Name, ascended the Iron Throne.
Catelyn Stark: When Rhaenyra heard of her
son's death, she collapsed.
She considered ending the war right then until
a raven arrived from her husband, Daemon.
Her son would be avenged.
Whispers slithered through the taverns and
back alleys of Flea Bottom.
Two men were found; one was a former gold
cloak, the other a rat catcher in the Red
Keep who knew all its secrets.
History remembers them only as Blood and Cheese.
One night, Queen Helaena entered the royal
apartments with her daughter and two sons
to put them to bed.
Without warning, Blood and Cheese burst in,
daggers in hand.
They told her that a debt was owed.
A son for a son.
Blood and Cheese demanded she choose which
son would be ripped from her forever.
Queen Helaena pleaded with the men to kill
her instead, but they refused.
Weeping, Helaena named her younger son Maelor.
Perhaps she thought the boy was too young
to understand, perhaps because the older boy
was King Aegon's firstborn son and heir.
"You hear that, little boy?"
Cheese whispered to the younger son.
"Your mama wants you dead."
Then Blood struck off the older boy's head
with a single blow.
When the guards burst in, they found Queen
Helaena still screaming, clasping her dead
son's body to her, mad with grief.
The blood of her children transformed a dynastic
dispute into a war of annihilation.
The grief and rage of losing a child could
burn down the world.
Either Aegon or Rhaenyra could live at the
end, but not both.
Robert Baratheon: One day King's Landing looked
up and saw two dragons circling their foul
city.
Daemon and Rhaenyra had come for her throne,
for the city was defenseless.
Aemond had taken the king's army from the
city, and worse, he'd taken his dragon Vhagar.
Seeing that resistance was hopeless, the small
council surrendered the city, the Queen Mother
Alicent, and the broken Queen Helaena.
But not King Aegon.
Somehow, despite his wounds and delirium,
he had vanished from the city.